[Music]
there's this crazy rumor on the internet
I think I know the answer that you want
to join the show Game of Thrones oh yeah
but I'm sure like a lot of things that
just I'm just curious how that rumor got
even started I mean the funny thing is
I've never seen Game of Thrones I I hate
to disappoint I know I hear it's
wonderful Catherine loves it it's fun to
you know I'll go crazy for it and I'm
and I think I need to just start from
the beginning because I tried to come in
in season two and I was a little
confused but I just one day someone said
you know what what show would it be fun
like just thinking about all those like
sort of pelts and horns and wolves and
horses or whatever they have and I and I
said I'd gave them a game of Thrones oh
so you're like a red carpet and you just
said to someone Game of Thrones I
thought it would be fun to sort of get
in that whole time period in and all the
crazy costumes and the next thing you
know everyone was like Christina what's
a star and I'm thrilled I'm sure it
would be I dunno lucky but I've not seen
it yet
but I hear it okay that's fantastic that
you said to a reporter you want to be on
the show but you've never seen it you
know I just had team like I say anything
if I'm on a red car I don't go to those
things much but whenever I'm around
Entertainment reporters I say the most
ludicrous things just to see if it will
show up and you probably had weird
rumors of things that you wanted to be
on oh I told people that I'm getting
into pornography and stuff then later on
my mom calls and she saw in the paper
and I trying Nonna happy she
telling a dream because I'm very
talented